para un valor de entrada de dado la
función efe entrega un valor de salida y
para satisfacer la siguiente ecuación
4x4 a más 7 b igual a menos 52 entonces
para cada entrada de la función f nos
dará una salida que satisfaga esta
relación para la a y para la b escribe
la fórmula para efe db en términos de ve
aquí si nos dan una b cuál será la an
que debemos tener como salida
la forma de pensar en esto es despejar a
de esta relación podemos pensar en nada
como una función debe vamos a escribirlo
4 a más 7 b igual a menos 52 si quiero
despejar a y dejarla en términos de b
cualquier número que tenga como b lo voy
a sustituir aquí y en contra de el valor
de salida vamos a hacer esto quiero
dejar sola a en el lado izquierdo y todo
lo demás irá al lado derecho incluyendo
las veces quiero pasar este 7 b del lado
izquierdo y esto lo puedo hacer restando
7 b en ambos lados de la ecuación
restamos y nos queda 7 b menos 7 b igual
a cero nos queda 4a igual a menos 52
menos 7 b
para aislarla tenemos que quitar el 4
que la multiplica y para esto dividió
todo entre 4 en ambos lados esto entre 4
del lado izquierdo nos queda la a sola
como queríamos cuanto es menos 52 64 52
es 40 más 12 40 entre 4 es 10 y 12 entre
4 nos va a dar igual a 3 por lo que nos
queda menos 3 menos siete cuartos de b
si nos dan una vez puedo poner aquí este
valor y calcular cuál será el valor de a
para que se satisfaga esta relación de
acá si quiero una fórmula de fv en
términos de b si tú me das una vez
usando mi función fpv la salida de esta
función va a ser menos 13 menos siete
cuartos de b porque la salida de mi
función tiene que ser una que satisfaga
o cumpla con esta ecuación espero que
esto les haya sido de ayuda